[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خذ نور القمر
[موسيقى]
نفس المحيط
محيانا شلال انا شلال من حبه عواطف
مكانك بالقلب
[موسيقى]
وبروحي ما
بين
عيوني ينسوا ليش ليش ليش
جميل انت ومثيره كل مزايا
[موسيقى]
جميل انت ومثير بكل مزاياك
حرام
الليل اللي
ل ولاد حرام حرام
حرام الليل يخلص
بالسوالف بس واني يا عيني
[موسيقى]
خلينا نروح يا ماما انا خايف منك تبعدني
عنك
يسلم علوح يا ماما صغيور
على قلبي وتلعب
خلينا نروح
انا خايف منك
يبعدني عنك
نسلم عن
[موسيقى]
جنبي ويتمشى
يغمز لي
برمشه
وانا قلبي حنين بسرعه
جنبي ويتمشى
يغمز
برمشني
وانا قلبي حنين
بسرعه يامن
وهذا ما يطمني يا وطن جمبي ويتمشى
يغمز لي برمشه
حارشني
[موسيقى]
انا قلبي حنين
بسرعه يامي
هذا ما يطم يا بابا
[موسيقى]
ينزل دمعاته
ابوس ختياداته حلوه حركات
لما
يرمز لي ويهراب
نزل
دمعاتك بوس اختي
حلوه حركات
لما اتقرب
يغمزني ويهراب
[موسيقى]
نزل معاتب ابو شفتي
لما اتقرب
لو يهرب
[موسيقى]
لك يا ماما
بعيوني ضي
بعيوني ضيع
وخدك
لمعايا هواه
بعيوني ضيع يا ويلي بعيوني ضيف
ومن وجنيتك
واشرق علي يا عليا والله معذبني
ما عندم
[موسيقى]
ويسالني
هالبطران عيني ليش وجهك
اصفار ليش وجهك
كل مرض ما
بينا من ترضي الاسمر ياويل والله سامي
ما عندهم
ويا محمد بويا محمد
قتليني ايش تت
[موسيقى]
يا محمد كاظم من الله
يا محمد مو هذا الله
يا محمد
خاف من الله
الله عيوني محمد قلبي سمعونا
[موسيقى]
ويا
محمد وذنبي
بين عداي والترمي
والترميني
تدري
النار اللي بقلبي
تدري الناس اللي بقلبي
تحرقني
وتشويني عيوني محمد قلبي محمد
البلبل ناغه غصن الفل
اه يا شقيق
النعمان
البلبل
غصن الفل
اجي محبوبي
بدي الاقي
محبوبي
بين الياسمين
والريحات يا عين بين الياسمين والريحان
كنا ستي على النبا
المحبوب صرنا سبعه
كنا صرتي على
النبا اجا المحبوب صرنا سما
وطلب بوسي ماطيته
[موسيقى]
ماضي
حرام يوم الجمعه يا عيني انت حرام يوم
الجيم
وحالي حالي حالي حالي مالي مالي
حالي حالي
[موسيقى]
الو
تفضل من هو اللي ما ندري
الو الو الو
تفضل تفضل منو ولمن تريد
حبيبك يمكن اني وكنت ناسي
[موسيقى]
واعتذر
غثيتك هواي
غلطان يمكن اني تاج راسي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
ما محتاج حبك حبني غيرك
[موسيقى]
افضل
من مصير
[موسيقى]
ما محتاج
حبك حبني غيرك
ومصير الان افضل من مصير
هسه القلب مرتاح
الهم والحزن
[موسيقى]
روضه قلت اسير
شو اسمك قول لي باسمك والله
ناسيك ناسيك
ما تقول لي باسمك
لك والله ناسيك ناسيك
تقدر اعرفك
من احاكيك اسف والله مو قصدي يا
حيران ما محتاج حبك حبني غير
[موسيقى]
صغيره كنت وانت صغير
بنظرات العيون
قالوا ترى
[موسيقى]
سيرت التوين
انا وترى ذولي
يحبوني
مثل النجمه والقمر
كبرنا
بعيونك حبيبي
[موسيقى]
وعلى الجرف قعدنا
لياليك
لكن نهر النخل عالي
غيرنا وكبرنا يا غالي
[موسيقى]
جرفك عدل ليالي
غيرنا وكبرنا
ظل النهر والنقل
مثل نجمه والقمر قمر حضنه
عيونك حبيبي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
تعالوا شوفوا حبيبي بالقلب
دلع ما عنده احساس ما عنده وفاه
[موسيقى]
ما عنده
تعال وشوفوا انا حبيبي بالقلب
ما عنده احساس ما عنده
ما عنده
ويرجع يزيد اموت بحسرتيني
[موسيقى]
ما عنده
هواي من اني مصيبه اذا نور العين هو اللي
يعلم عيون
حبيته ووفيته
مصيبه اذا نور العين هو اللي يعملي
حبيبي بالقلب
ما عنده احساس ما عنده
حبيبي ما عنده
[موسيقى]
ذهبت الليل وابكي اقول لك
ما عنده ندور ما عنده
الاجل بعمري يضحك
الليل وابكي
ما عنده
ما حاسب يجي فجاه حبيبي
[موسيقى]
القلب
ما عنده احساس ما عنده وفين ما عنده
لا لاي لا لا لا
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]